يعني في بدايتها الطبيعيه لم تكن محمله
بالافكار السياسيه والافكار الايديولوجيه
لكن مثل اي يعني اييه لعبه مثل اي منتج
يعني يقبل عليه الناس يتم استثماره على
المستوى الماني والمستوى السياسي او
الايديولوجيا او يعني التعبير عن
الانقسامات الاثنيه في المجتمعات للاسف
هذا هو الوجه المظلم
للاستثمارات التي تمت من خلال كره القدم
ولكن يعني ربما نتحدث عن هذا الامر همم في
الحلقه يعني همم هناك
رهانات من ينتصر من من الطرف الذي بيده ان
يجعل اللعبه نظيفه منزهه عن الغرض ومن
بيده ان يستثمر هذه اللعبه من اجل زرع لقد
وتعميم الكراهيه يعني هذه هذا سؤال مفتوح
وهذا اساله على نفسي واساله عليكم انه من
المسؤول من الضابط الذي عليه ان يتحكم في
مسار هذه الايه